bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got jesse
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
my pleasure thanks for having me for
sure uh let's start
with just how you're spending your time
right now i know you guys have the hedge
fund and then you've got this new
product maybe let's start
with uh the hedge fund give us an
overview again of strict
leviathan and uh what the focus is there
yeah absolutely so strix we founded
three years ago we launched our fund in
april of 18. so we've just now crossed
over the three-year anniversary of
having a track record which
is pretty rare in this space uh to find
folks that last that long
and it's been going phenomenally well
the team's grown now to
about eight eight folks or so the
investment team there
uh has has grown pretty significantly
and at the end of the day like that fund
it's a you think about it as defensive
crypto we started it because i took a
little bit of money in 2017 and turned
it into a lot of money and then back to
a little bit of money personally
i was like there has to be a better way
to participate in this space you know
there's a lot of people that that argue
for
for hotel and i just found that i'm not
one of the people that can tolerate an
80
drawdown like it's just not for
everybody right uh and so i
i wanted some way to have exposure to
the space that that
just felt uh felt safer felt defensive
and that's exactly what the fund has
done over the last three years so it's
been really neat to see it sort of
manifest
itself and to to uh follow through with
the vision that we set out
and then we're just we're beginning now
given the size of the team we're
beginning to be able to spend
time and energy in areas that we haven't
been able to focus on in the past so the
the
set of strategies that we run where
historically
they've been you know predominantly
momentum strategies you can think of
them like commodities trading strategies
by far and large
we've we've really added some pretty
sophisticated machine learning over the
last year
in statistical analysis into the into
the mix and it's just neat to see
new things uh come to fruition in the
platform
and so when you think about kind of
taking a defensive strategy
uh during a bear market no-brainer right
obviously
as you said nobody likes to take an 80
drawdown uh right to the chin uh but how
does that play out during a bull market
so kind of like what are the
opportunities
and the challenges with operating that
type of strategy in a bull market
yeah absolutely so if you think about
what the objective of the fund is we're
trying to return a better risk adjusted
return over a complete market cycle
so that means slower drawdown smaller
volatility we're trying to capture
60 to 70 percent of the gains in a bull
market and zero to 20
of the losses in a bear market and in
aggregate it's just a
more comfortable uh exposure in a lot of
ways
we found that that resonates with a lot
of family offices and and uh high net
worth individuals who
are just sort of beginning to dip their
toes in the water here and it just
that feels like a more comfortable
investment the challenge there is that
in
a bull market like we're in you you sort
of you're always going to lag
the aggregate performance it's just part
of the strategy set
and so you've got to find investors that
understand that that's part of the
objective
that it's we're not here to outperform
bitcoin like that's not
uh our sole purpose in life we're not
here to outperform
uh sort of all of these these uh new and
exotic tokens that are on in the market
and there's plenty of vehicles to to do
that and there's folks that are
phenomenal
at that specific investment style and
it's just it's a different approach so
it's really been
we've spent a lot of energy thinking
through how do we explain what we do and
the why
the why of what we do to folks and uh
that probably is the largest challenge
we experience
and when you think about kind of how you
measure success what are like the kpis
so when you're talking to an investor
uh who's somebody who's evaluating this
strategy versus other strategies that
they could look at
uh obviously it's not just a return
what are some of the other kpis that
they're looking at and kind of
find importance in uh if they choose
that this strategy something that they
would want to incorporate in portfolio
yeah we measure two things predominantly
it's sortino ratio
and drawdown so our objective is is to
limit drawdowns they'll still exist
given we're
a long short fund um but our objective
is to limit those so if you think about
bitcoin's history since we've been
operating as a fund
drawdown is sort of 80 85 percent um our
drawdown is a fraction of that max
drawdown and so it's it's really it's
about providing
sort of comfort in in those numbers and
then sortino like our objective there is
uh capture more of the wins and and
fewer the losses and
and that stat more than a sharp ratio or
anything else
does a great job uh demonstrating that
ability
explain that a little bit more because i
think that that's probably a stat that
most people aren't familiar with
yeah so certain ratio it's basically a
numeric calculation that allows you to
look at both the wins and the losses of
of
the fund and from a return perspective
uh and be able to put sort of a measure
to that
uh that can say for the the gains that
you've experienced
compared to the losses you've
experienced uh sort of what is the
what is the relative ratio there uh so
it's just it's it's an objective way to
measure investment vehicles
that that looks not just at raw return
but looks at
uh the risk and the gains
got it and so you now have a kind of a
spin out if you will you guys have built
building a technology platform uh it's a
consumer-facing technology platform
uh mccarra uh talk a little bit just
about where did this idea come from and
then what have you guys built so far
yeah absolutely so we founded strix in
2018 with the thesis that the
institutional infrastructure in crypto
really was
non-existent or abysmal and uh with that
thesis
ended up building this octopus software
platform it's an investment management
platform and
we've identified it as effectively the
most robust investment management
platform in the space
and that's what we've used to run the
strikes of iathen funds over the last
three years
last summer we got together as a team
who really did some analysis around
how do we open up these markets to to a
broader set of people
a broader set of investors as a hedge
fund from a regulatory perspective we're
limiting
limited to who we can sell to right we
the nest fund is a three c seven fund
so we can accept qualified purchasers
which means you have to have five
million dollars of investable assets to
participate in our vehicle
and and that's not like it's great we
love our lps
we've done a phenomenal job for them but
we want to be able to to touch more
people we want more people to have
access to this
asset class and so as we thought about
that we we really we started to look at
why aren't people allocating here what
is the issue with this asset class that
causes people to sit on the sidelines
and so we went we spoke to a bunch of
prospective customers doctors lawyers
bankers tech execs
and we started to see this repeated
message like the space is just too
intimidating
we've got 9 000 different assets now
everything's named exactly the same
thing or with some peculiar name that's
impossible to pronounce uh
you've got a completely foreign lexicon
that people have to learn
to figure out how to interact and then
sort of all the tools and technologies
uh sort of the wallets like they've
gotten so much
friendlier over the last couple years
but they're still pretty intimidating
and the risk of loss is total right you
make a mistake and you lose all your
money
so that's nobody wants to have egg on
their face or be the sort of clown in
the room by making a mistake
and so we looked at that and we looked
at what we built on the octopus side
we said there has to be a way that we
can provide people easier access to the
space
and so we found that we found
effectively with the sec an avenue to
register as
crypto's first robo advisor so we're an
sec registered investment advisor
with the sec and that allows us to
effectively build investment baskets
that
clients can come and select these
baskets are the equivalent you can think
of them like
thematic etfs so an investor can come to
makara
sign up they go through a q a so unlike
sort of traditional robo advisories
where you're trying to figure out your
risk profile
like my low risk medium risk high risk
everything in this asset class is risky
it's risky risky
or riskiest uh so the goal here is it's
more about figuring out your interest
like why do you want to participate in
this space
some people are like look i just think
bitcoin's interesting so great we've got
a bitcoin basket some people could say
look i'm concerned about inflation
that's my number one worry
and we could give them a modern
inflation hedge basket that's half
bitcoin half tokenized gold rebalanced
on a quarterly basis
and so there's a bunch of different
avenues that that we can utilize
to to get people on the platform and
and to make that process simple like the
goal here is you don't have to
understand all the nuances and
complexity of this asset class
to participate and so when you think
through
um kind of spinning out a a product that
you've built
uh maybe just walk through kind of how
you guys have historically have split
resources internally
and then why spin it out first keep it
internal so the
the strix team historically i mean
that's grown into a phenomenal business
it's a profitable operating entity we've
got
a great team there of investment
professionals that are focused on
uh building and deploying the best
strategies we we can in that fund
and so it's exciting to see us reach
that milestone it's a pretty meaningful
milestone
but as we looked at this we recognized
there was this opportunity to build this
new product
and so we decided to sort of spin it out
as its own entity and raise capital
specifically to go grow that vehicle
and the neat thing is that these two um
the two businesses are very
complementary in nature
so the improvements we make on the
octopus trading platform within strix
benefit the makara clients
and the the learnings we make on the
mcara side in terms of the passive
products go back and
into the strict side so being able to to
spin it out and have it two dedicated
teams allow us to really get
the proper resourcing on on each side
and grow the organization successfully
yeah and so when you start to roll this
out what's the importance of that sec
registration
right obviously you guys being the first
ones that get it uh just kind of being
first to do a lot of stuff with
regulators is important but how do you
view the importance of uh
of actually sec registration around a
robo advisor in this space
yeah i think one of the issues with with
crypto is that over the last decade
most organizations and most startups
here have shied away from regulation
because it was hard and challenging the
regulators quite frankly weren't ready
and so you've ended up with you know
international exchanges that
that exclude us customers you end up
with all of these
uh you know some of the most successful
businesses just don't want to touch the
us and
we didn't feel like it should be that
way so going forward with mccarran the
thesis was being crypto's first
sec registered investment advisor we can
demonstrate to these market participants
who are standing on the sidelines and
are concerned about
how bizarre this space is we can
demonstrate that we've gone
sort of the route to do this the right
way and so
that registration allows us to give
investment advice it allows us to put
together these investment baskets and be
able to make those recommendations to
individuals
and it also sets up a number of
requirements and considerations around
how we run the business
like things like we can't charge
transaction fees to our users
so and all of our sort of billing
methodologies need to be very clear and
transparent
so it sets this expectation like many
people are familiar with working with
advisors historically
they know what that experience should
look like and now they can get sort of a
similar experience
in the world of crypto and is the
expectation that this will be 100 of
people's exposure uh who are users of
the platform or will this be kind of one
piece and then they may actually go
uh buy and hold or do something else on
another platform like how do you think
about
uh almost like the percentage of wallet
share uh for a user that comes onto the
platform
yeah so the neat thing here it's like
this is not an exchange the last thing
crypto needs is another exchange we've
got a bunch of phenomenal ones
and you know and everybody that was an
exchange has built some kind of buy and
hold functionality into their app over
the last year
so users that are in crypto like they
are taking care of uh they're taken care
of
this is targeting net new users who
otherwise don't have exposure to the
space or they may have a little bit of
exposure and don't know what to do
and so the objective is get people in
the door get them the sort of the
quickest and simplest exposure
into the asset class and then as they
grow with us
with their sophistication so will our
product and its feature set
one of the really important things that
in addition to just the investment of
advice that we're giving is this this
component of education
so we think people participate in this
asset class for two reasons
one the gains are compelling like that's
an obvious no-brainer
but two they're curious right like to
some extent this is liquid angel
investing
and people really just they participate
because they want to understand what's
happening here
and it moves so quickly on a day-to-day
basis that's very hard to keep up
and so the objective with macar is to
mirror and match
those investment baskets that
individuals are are making investments
into
with educational content that allows
them to easily and simply digest
what they're investing in and there was
some stat that was released three or
four weeks ago that said 60
of crypto investors don't actually
understand what they're holding like
that terrifies me that's not how this
should be like people should understand
what they're investing in
and and they should do in a way like i
want to be able to walk into a dinner
party and be able to have
some commentary on on where my money is
and why it's exciting and interesting
so that doesn't happen really on
exchanges today that doesn't happen in
existing venues and so being able to
match
uh those baskets and the education into
one unified experience we think
really unlocks the store to new market
participants
when you think of the ideal customer for
makara or the ideal user uh who is that
is that a
kind of a large uh net worth and uh a
lot of liquid assets into
cryptocurrency is that somebody who's
more of kind of a beginner
a younger person just is there kind of a
persona if you will or a customer
segment that you're specifically focused
on
yeah and i mean the only thing here is
that there's no sort of minimum
investment or there's no floor it's you
know it's not a hedge fund where you
have to have hundreds of thousands of
dollars invested
this really it's a product available for
everybody and we want to focus on
on that concept our objective is is to
make this asset class
uh accessible to people that just by far
too confused
uh you know i think the the
working professional the doctor lawyer
banker somebody that's working 40 50
hours a week in their job and then they
come home and they spend time with their
families
that persona makes sense to me you don't
have time to go and understand
all of the nuances of this asset class
but you're curious and interested
and this gives you that path to gain
exposure simply
uh and quickly and to learn from it
yeah and then how do you think about
when it's a robo advisor
obviously people want to have an opinion
right but there's
almost this like automated element to it
it sounds like really the experience is
like come in i kind of tell you what my
goals are
and then your software and platform is
able to then guide me in the right
direction is that a fair way to think
about it
it's exactly right got it uh all right
let's switch topics uh we were talking a
little bit about regulation
sec uh registration uh there's a lot of
people
hoping that the sec will bless them with
the uh kind of
elusive bitcoin etf uh i don't know what
the count is
uh recently but i think that we're up to
like eight nine ten different
coins nine or ten nine or ten okay uh
you tend to think that maybe we
shouldn't be holding our breath for
these explain kind of your perspective
on the bitcoin etf and kind of why maybe
you've got a little bit different
uh viewpoint yeah i mean this is a
fascinating one given it's been such a
hot topic of conversation for for
literally the last four years like
particularly given 2008 it was like oh
the etf's gonna get approved and that's
going to save crypto
and then a pivoted institutional
capital's coming and that's going to
save crypto
and so we've been talking about etfs for
for as long as i can remember
you know what what's the advantage to an
etf well certainly i think it opens up
access to this market
to a broader set of people that don't
have
that don't feel comfortable making
investments here today and
it's like it works sort of within your
brokerage account like it simplifies
that that exposure
but we have that today between all these
exchange trusts
between grayscale and bitwise like there
are vehicles already to do that
so it doesn't it's not sort of this
phenomenal new invention
and the the big challenge here that i
think is is often overlooked is that
these etfs you're basically taking a
24x7 traded asset and you're wrapping it
up into a
banker hour vehicle a nine to five
banker hour vehicle
and if you look at at bitcoin and its
movements over the last couple years
the largest movements in this asset
class typically happen
when the stock market's closed you look
at march 12th of last year that was
overnight in the u.s hours you look at
thanksgiving like thanksgiving is
repeatable you can guarantee that
there'll be fireworks on thanksgiving
every year
new year's eve is another classic
example so all of these environments
that may be phenomenal
buying opportunities or maybe selling
opportunities for
for all you you know like you're locked
out in the construct of an etf because
the market's closed
so that's i think it's something that
it's easily overlooked with people that
are thinking about that as
a vehicle and the the second component
is
really it's around like do you want to
participate in technological revolutions
so
why was bitcoin created it was like
we're here to replace the traditional
financial system we want to have an
alternative something that's very
different
and instead you're just packaging it up
into that traditional structure and
providing it
on these brokerage accounts buyers of
that aren't actually participating in
in bitcoin they don't hold the bitcoin
they can't get access to the bitcoin
that's in that etf uh you're not you're
not really
a participant in in all of this
technology technology revolution
and so we think if the objective is just
simplifying access to
to these new investors we think there's
there's better ways like what we're
building in makara
um or even just looking at the the
exchange landscape and its evolution
over the last couple years
there are better ways to participate in
this this uh revolution than just buying
bitcoin in an etf
one of the things that i always laugh
about is it feels like uh
on monday mornings the institution uh
they come into work and they're like
what happened this weekend and they see
like
the kids were out while parents were
sleeping did all kinds of crazy stuff
left a mess and then like now jump back
in bed and are pretending to sleep again
right and so there is this element of uh
of the institutions don't get to play
when uh when all the the kind of crypto
degenerates right i said in a loving way
uh get to uh do all the crazy stuff so i
i definitely agree there
uh do you think an etf would be bad like
if it gets approved
you know assuming it does get approved
at some point is that a negative
uh kind of event no definitely not bad
it's a phenomenal uh milestone for the
industry and it's a validate stamp of
approval
right uh i just think we we've had
baited breath everybody's had baited
waiting for baited breath
for years waiting for this etf to be
here and i just think
like it's not this magical end-all
be-all point in time that changes
everything for the industry
yeah and when you start to think through
uh kind of the regulatory environment
in general what has your experience been
right so you've got a hedge fund
obviously
then you've got a consumer-facing
platform that has sec registration
uh do you feel like uh the right the
regulatory environment is is abrasive to
crypto do you feel like it's just normal
for kind of finance
uh organizations in general maybe it's
actually better for crypto companies
just
what's your personal experience yeah
it's been really interesting kind of
tracking that over the last
four years we've been running this
business given we sort of we started in
2018
and so regulation was uh ostensibly
very opaque or totally absent and you
sort of everybody had to go to their
lawyers and say here's what we want to
do and then the lawyers would give you
some advice and they say
you know but that's our best guess like
we don't actually know how this is going
to work
and so when we started strix you know we
configured it in a way that we thought
was regulatory
the appropriate route and we're
operating in washington state
so new york and washington state have
the two state regulators that ostensibly
have looked at crypto
the hardest and have built sort of
specific regular regulation around it
and we discovered sort of 15 months into
operations that the state had a
different opinion
than what our legal team did on on how
to structure these things and so we had
to go through a restructuring in the
middle of 2019
and for a startup in in this asset class
like it's just ridiculous how much
capital gets spent on legal bills
right i think if you go start a
traditional hedge fund trading equities
you go plop down 30 40 grand you get all
your legal structure in place and away
you go
all said and done on the strict side i
think we're close to three quarters of a
million dollars
we've invested in into legal bills not
because we we've
done anything wrong or it's like because
it's just opaque like the lawyers don't
know and so you're playing this constant
guessing game
and and and the regulation continues to
uh to change and so as it changes you've
got to sort of adapt and respond and
react
and it's just it's goofy it's not it's
not a good way for
for startups it's not a good environment
for startups to be able to function and
sort of
it's those that have been able to put up
with it that have made it this far
that's actually but sort of so that's
the state side then you look at that in
comparison on the federal side like the
sec is actually
you know for all the grief a lot of
people give the sec they've done
phenomenal work over the last couple
years
trying to provide more and more clarity
into what is a very dynamic and quickly
evolving
market and and it also seems like the
sec
you know they're much more willing to
engage and have conversations around the
the right way to
to do this uh in in a way where where
some state regulators have really pushed
back
so it's been fascinating to watch sort
of those two tracks evolve over the last
couple years
i feel pretty good about the state of
regulation in crypto in 2021
um i think it only gets better from here
i think every month and every quarter
that goes by we get
further clarity about how to do this the
right way
i think startups in today's environment
are at a structural advantage
from that regulatory it's like we sort
of it's the oregon trail of crypto like
we've
we forged the river and and hunted our
food and and now we're
on the west coast and everybody can sort
of benefit from uh from that work we've
done
uh so it's it's been a fascinating
evolution over the last couple years
i love it you mentioned washington uh
i'm in miami
uh why not move why not go to a
different state
yeah i mean i think that's something
that we're considering in fact our team
has started that process so
we've got members in barcelona we have
our cio just moved to north carolina
and you know it's fascinating to me so
washington state just this week passed a
capital gains tax
which is like it's an unfriendly tax for
entrepreneurs
it's basically saying we don't want you
to run and operate a company in this
state
and and so thinking about that and
thinking about the regulatory
environment that exists here
it's really fascinating to compare and
contrast that to what's been happening
in in miami
particularly with the mayor right it's
so it's so amazing to watch the mayor
interact with people on twitter and
really want to build an ecosystem
and be actively involved and participate
you know
it's it's a rare it's very rare to see
that
and it's been exciting and invigorating
and
and it really it makes people consider
that that move so
certainly something that we're looking
at on our side
it's hilarious to me incentives run the
world
and taxes are the greatest incentive in
the world right
or one of at least in terms of uh you
can use them to
uh attract talent and companies and and
resources
or you can use them to push them away
and uh there's arguments from both sides
uh you know each situation has to be
evaluated on its own
but for the most part uh it seems like
certain states are headed
uh in the wrong direction and therefore
they're losing citizens
uh literally i think it was just in the
latest consensus you saw
that a couple of states like california
and new york literally lost uh political
uh representation because they've lost
so many citizens
and so naturally where are those people
going they're going to states where
uh it's more conducive to business and
to personal wealth
building right like it doesn't seem like
it's uh rocket science
um that if you increase the incentive to
go somewhere people will follow
well it's kind of funny given you're
effectively being paid to move
right if you're gonna start taxing
capital gains at that point and and
there are
avenues and venues i can go to that that
aren't going to tax those gains
i'm being paid to make that transition
uh
so it's in my eyes it's pretty
short-sighted uh
and particularly like from the
entrepreneurial perspective
it's not as if i have taken market pay
over the last four years
you know the returns that i make from
from spending my time energy and effort
in this business
their capital gains returns because i've
invested a decade of my life
here and and i've done that at the cost
of sort of short-term
short-term income uh and so it's pretty
easy to look and
and washington's funny given you've got
you know you've got bezos you've got
gates here and so i think that sort of
the legislature looks at those
individuals and say aha sort of here's
some easy money
and so let's go tackle that but but they
ensnare kind of this whole
entrepreneurial ecosystem
in the midst of that and it's just the
incentives comment is exactly spot on
all right well miami's open come on
let's go we'll uh we'll
talk about it more we'll be down for
bitcoin 2021
that's going to be the next recruiting
session don't worry uh in
in terms of the bull market that we're
in right now what's been the biggest
surprise to you
you know we talk about this a lot
internally like i think if you look at
the 2017 bull market
in the midst of that we had sort of six
or seven pretty material drawdowns over
the course of 2017
and they were fairly extended uh periods
of time and from a duration perspective
you know 2018 2018 the argument was the
institutions are coming the institutions
are coming we finally saw them
materialize in 2020
and particularly that the back half of
2020 it's not stopped in 2021
and i i think i like to think through
sort of what's the difference between
the 2017 market participant and the 2021
market participant
2017 market participant predominantly
retail you know this is a speculative
asset class so they're here to speculate
but you're sort of you've made your
investment it goes up in value
it's not as if you have a ton of
additional dry powder to continue making
investments as things
uh as these these dips occur uh
and so and particularly sort of as the
market fell apart in 20 2018
like that's a scary proposition to a
retail investor
2021 like it feels structurally
different to me like these institutions
there they've now accepted that this
asset class is not going away
the tooling and infrastructure to
support their involvement in the asset
class is finally here from a custodial
perspective from an auditor perspective
um even just from sort of the the
general conversation in the media like
it's no longer
it's no longer crazy to say you're going
to hold bitcoin on your balance sheet
it's now
you've got this aura of being innovative
by doing it
those those investors they're not taking
their entire uh
you know their entire investable balance
sheet and putting it into crypto on day
one
they're looking at this as a long-term
opportunity and so
the dips that we're seeing now they seem
to be being bought up
much quicker than we saw in 2017
like much quicker and so that that uh
that period of sort of market recovery
uh it goes by much faster and sort of a
way we go
whether or not that continues through
this year i think is anybody's guess
certainly we had like the back half of
20 it was uh
just unbelievable what the drumbeat of
news was sort of every day it was some
new
uh some new piece of material
institutional news that slowed a bit now
but you know i don't think it's going
away so that's how
like comparing contrasting 17 to 21
that's how we think about it
what do you think is the kind of back
half of 2021 look like
do we see you know bitcoin much higher
will it
top out at 60k like just kind of
understanding you can't predict the
future just directionally how do you
think about where we are
uh this year in a bull market and kind
of what's to come
yeah i mean this is my favorite like i
have no idea nobody knows
uh you know we don't have enough data in
this asset class it's totally
speculative
most of it is behavioral in nature uh
and so
it it could continue to go up i think
there's a number of
arguments i could make for why why we
are sort of at the beginning of a much
more prolonged
bull market um we also could could see a
topic
and it could fall apart again much like
it did in in 2017.
um there's fewer reasons in my eyes for
why that that could be the case
at this point in time i think looking at
the macroeconomic picture
uh there there is so much cash sitting
on the sidelines
uh right now and there is an appetite
for speculative investment
uh there's an interest in in generating
above
normal return this is an asset class
that has done that historically very
well
uh and so to think like this isn't going
away
so if it continues to if this asset
class continues to exist and those
market conditions
continue to exist it sort of feels
natural that we'll see
sort of an evolution and flow of capital
into it uh but how that manifests and
into what assets that manifests in is is
i think anybody's guess it's
like the last two weeks just watching
bitcoin and ethereum uh
as two markets here and how they've
behaved and reacted
uh it's you know it's a fascinating
market to participate in right now
yeah i think what's so interesting to me
is
uh what you one mentioned everything
happening a little bit faster
uh but also when you compare it
historically to 2017 so far we're
further ahead than we would have been in
that bull market
and so uh some of that is like the speed
at which we go from these little like
mini boom and bust cycles and kind of
roll through
uh the full cycle but also just from uh
days since the last halving just how far
ahead we are
um it's quite impressive and uh and
frankly um i think as uh
as you can look at the market structure
a lot of us just driven by you have a
lot of folks coming into the market with
really really big
pocketbooks uh and they want uh you know
access to an asset that
60 hasn't moved in a year there's more
and more coming off of exchanges and
just from a market structure standpoint
they got to pay more for it right and so
it's just fascinating
uh to see it's almost overly simplistic
uh in terms of the explanation
um and that actually may be one of the
reasons why some people in the legacy
world are missing it
right but uh but but um you know i i
don't know i'm with you like
nobody knows the future but uh but but
it seems almost too simple
uh and so it's constantly getting people
to kind of gut check themselves and
recheck and recheck and recheck all the
data
uh and their analysis to see that
everything's still kind of intact
yeah i mean i think the really neat
thing to me is is i think at the end of
2017
and and through 2018 2019 like we were
laughed at like you'd go
anywhere and you say i run a crypto
hedge fund literally laughed at
and now those same people are coming
back and they're asking how do they get
involved in the in the ecosystem in the
in the industry like
uh there was at the at the conclusion of
the 2017 market i think there was a lot
of question
does this asset class continue to exist
like people ask that over and over and
over
you're not seeing that right now like
this is an established asset class it
will be here
will it be the same set of of tokens and
assets that are on the you know the
top 10 by market cap list today probably
not like
this is liquid angel investing these
things changing it's all this is all a
big experiment
it's all a big experiment in human
behavior and psychology and technology
and so this will change but this asset
class as a whole
it's not going away it's here for the
long run yeah i tend to agree
where can we send people to find out
more about strix or uh
makara yeah absolutely so makara you can
find it makara m-a-k-a-r-a
digital d-i-g-i-t-a-l dot com we've got
a wait list ahead of our launch there
and anybody on the way that joins the
waitlist
to receive six months of of uh fee-free
investment management
when we launch and then the top 100 uh
referrers
will receive a 50 pre-funded account at
launch so check that out and get on the
wait list there
and then strix you can find it strix
s-t-r-i-x
fund f-u-n-d-com awesome well listen
jesse i really really appreciate you
taking the time to do this
i always enjoy talking with you and we
love to do it again in the future
perfect i'll see you in miami soon